hi everyone
hi philip hi philip
so
um
for those who don't know phillip um he's
the last speaker for today it's philipp
schmidt and he's a machine learning
engineer and the tech lead at hugging
face where he leads the collaboration
with the amazon sagemaker team
so if you have any questions about
sagemaker
in the next couple of days just post
them on the forum and i guess philip
will help you there um he's also really
passionate about democratizing and
productionizing cutting edge nlp models
and improving the use of them for deep
learning
and today he's going to explain to us
how to do managed training with amazon
sagemaker and how you paste transformers
so i think here we're going to actually
see
how to push models to the hub which you
know most people i think are interested
in learning so then they can use those
models for building their spaces
so i'll share the
video and then we'll come back for a q a
hi everyone my name is phillip i'm the
tech lead for our collaboration with aws
and amazon sagemaker today i'm happy to
talk to you about managed training with
amazon sagemaker and heightened phase
transformers i will show you in a few
minutes how you can train and
automatically push your hiking phase
transformer model using amazon sagemaker
to our highly phase model hub for those
of you who don't know amazon sagemaker
amazon sagemaker is a fully managed
machine learning service that provides
everyone with the ability to build train
and deploy machine learning models
quickly
let's get started
um i already started amazon search maker
notebook instance which is like
managed jupyter environment by aws you
will get access to the notebook
i guess through some resources it's on
github so you can find it pretty easily
in the beginning i included a few links
so we have several um resources and
documentation about how to use amazon
sagemaker with hugging face transformers
we have a special documentation we have
a lot of examples we already did a few
workshops though the cast a couple of
months maybe some of you have been there
and then we have a dedicated sagemaker
section in our hiking phase forum so if
you are participating on the community
even the next couple of days feel free
to ask any question you have in this
community forum sections okay
let's get started so what we are going
to do is we are going to train a
multi-class text classification model
using transformers and data sets of
course and as data said we are going to
use the emotion data set and as model we
are going to use the
distal bird encased
the first step is of course we need to
install our
dependencies in this case we are using
the sagemaker package which is the
sagemaker python sdks to interact with
the sagemaker platform behind the scenes
then we have transformers and a data
sets version to pre-process our data set
since i rent this already i have my
dependencies stalled
and then
we can jump into the next section which
is permission so
um this notebook can be run inside of
aws using amazon sagemaker notebook
instances or the sagemaker studio
then searchmaker provides a nice way to
get access to permission so if you want
to run your training on sagemaker of
course you will need permissions to
access your data on s3 or to start your
training job with the correct instance
type since we are running inside of aws
i can execute a code cell which
basically gets our permission role gets
our s3 bucket which we will use to store
our trading assets and then the region
we will run in
if you are going to run
or want to run sagemaker training or
training jobs and from your local
machine or from a virtual machine or
basically from anywhere else
and there's also like a selling code
that you can comment in
and then yeah basically get access to
the same resources as i am
to start our training we of course want
to pre-process
our data set and what's very nice about
amazon sagemaker is that
we can split up pre-processing and
trading into two different parts and
then for example only um or have the
pre-processed data set already available
when running our training so what we are
going to do is we pick up our tokenizer
and pick up our emotion data set and um
pre-process it um using data sets
and to yeah our preferred format so we
are loading the data set we are
tokenizing it we have like a small
little helper function for it and then
we changing the labels and um setting
the format for our
columns
and then what we are going to do is we
are going to leverage the s3 file system
integration into data sets which
basically allows us to save our
pre-processed data set to amazon s3 to
then later use in
our training job so we don't need to
pre-process our data set again
when running the training so that's
pretty nice so we can upload our data
set which is then the error file created
by the data sets library as well the sd
configuration files
after we have uploaded it we can get
like to the nice part to create our
estimator and start our training
the height and face estimator is um
yeah basically a python class which
includes all of the
nits and grits you need to start your
training so when we scroll down a bit
here we can see the hanging face um
estimator which says okay we want to use
our drain.pi script it is located in our
scripts folder we want to use a p3
instance which has a nvidia gpu mounted
we want to use one instance so if you
want to run distributed training you can
easily change the number to two and then
you can leverage multi gpus and multi
nodes and we have the name of course for
our job which will be used to look into
the results afterwards we have our role
which we
got in the beginning to have access to
our data sets we have uploaded to s3 and
then we have our image which is
basically the container where
transformers and pi torch tensorflow
datasets is installed which will be used
for our training we have a python
version and then the hyperparameters and
the hyperparameters are
parameters we can pass into our training
job so you can imagine that when running
a training sagemaker will start the ec2
instance
which starts starts our container and
then executes
our training with python3
in this case drain.pi and then provides
the hyperparameter we define here as cli
arguments so the key would be the key in
our argument and then we have the value
so the training script we are going to
use has an aux passer included which
accepts all of our training parameters
and then
this can be used inside our training
since we want to push our model to the
hanging phase hub we can use the hiking
phase hub notebook login and then
provide our um pm required hyper
parameters to push our model to the
hiking phase hub which is the push to
hub
argument of course then the model id of
our new created repository
when we want to save our model since we
are running like one epoch
i guess it doesn't make that much sense
to save every but if we are going to
change it to free
then um the trainer would save after
each
epoch our model to the hiking phase hub
and we can like directly interact with
it but let's keep it for now with one so
the training will run faster and then of
course our hugging face tool
so we can log
in that's my username
copy my password
hit login
and we are logged into our account
we set our hyperparameters we create our
hugging phase
instant class and get an error because
we forget our comma here
create our hiking phase estimator and
then what's nice
so to start our training we can run the
dot fit method and
you are probably aware of that we have
pre-processed our data set inside our
notebook and uploaded to s3 where we
defined
variables to the location so our data
set for the train is saved in this s3
location
and we can now provide um the s3 ui into
our
estimator into the fit method and then
stage maker will load before the
training starts the data set from s3
into our environment and we can access
it directly from the file system
so we can start our training with
executing the cell i intentionally
provided a weight faults method
which tells the sdk to not wait until
the training job is done if we would
remove it then sagemaker would basically
connect to the ec2 instance and we would
see the
[Music]
comment like the output of the training
job the logs everything directly inside
of the notebook but since we provide our
token and i guess it's better to provide
faults and rather look up the training
job in the management console and
additionally you i have
a waiter script which basically um
checks if the drainage job is done so we
can execute it and then the cell will be
completed after our training job is
finished
and then we can access our model
by
running this nice little code which
dynamically creates our
um
in-face url we have our username and
then the model hub id we provided
earlier and then if we jump into our
model page
and i run the training already the
trainer and sagemaker has created a
nicely model card with our accuracy and
the loss we can see okay which model we
have to train on which data set
and we can see the hyper parameter which
we have provided um using our hyper
parameter
we can see our training results
we run it for one epoch we have the
framework version
super nice we can run the inference
directly since it's already on the
inference api available
i guess we can while it's loading
checking into our files and here we can
see basically everything is correctly
saved by our
training job and by sh maker and we can
share the model with our friends and
then the ku's can use it
perfect
and then
afterwards there's um
yeah
like visual on how stage maker works you
can like look into it to understand a
bit better what's happening but the easy
way is basically we have a hacking phase
deep learning container or training
container which includes all of our
libraries we need we have our data set
on s3
and then when starting our training shop
with the sdk stagemaker will start our
instances pulls the dlc runs the dlc on
the container with our script loads our
pre-trained model from the hiding phase
hub
loads our data set from s3 and then runs
the training and at the end
you can also save it to s3 and then
deploy directly with sagemaker but we
like cut it a step and saved it to the
hub and then use the inference api for
it
then additionally i have provided a nice
little example on how you can use and
leverage already existing training
script so i guess you are familiar with
the hackingfast transformer repository
and in there we have an examples
directory which includes a lot of
scripts for a lot of different tasks
including nlp vision speech and all of
those scripts are compatible with
sagemaker so
to use them search maker provides a git
config where we can point to our github
repository to which branch we want to
use and then we can basically run again
our estimator and run the training job
and then the example script will be used
directly from github and you can all
only need to provide the hyper
parameters and don't need to write your
own training script if there is already
an existing one for you use case
thank you for
listening
i hope to see you all in the community
event come in the next couple of days if
you have questions about sagemaker or
run into some issues
feel free to contact me
and looking forward on what you will
create
and we're back
thanks for that nice talk philip
it's uh super cool to see that you can
push your models to the hub by kind of
using the same
parameters in the trainer
just the hub model id and the name super
cool
speaking of that we have a question
which is
does the sagemaker estimator leverage
the trainer from transformers
how is the training being done is it did
you did you reinvent the trainer
uh yes
no
like it really depends on what like
flavor of transformers you are using so
material like the talk before you for
example used um tensorflow and keras and
for this you would like need to use the
keras callback we have for the hugging
phase hub to push your model to the hub
in my example i used pytorch and then of
course the trainer so it's like uh
yeah a normal python training script you
could like run outside of sagemaker on
your local machine with with like the
parameters and then with the nice
integration from the trainer into the
hiking phase hub we just needed to
provide our like token and the hub id
and then we were able to push it like
automatically i think one thing we
should say and people need to watch out
is that if you are running your training
in sagemaker in an agape environment so
you could also configure like vpc
configuration that
your training don't has internet
connection then of course the
integration with the hub wouldn't work
but i
expect since we are like an open
community and share everything with
everyone and we are not running training
inside air gapped environments this week
cool cool
so another question is
can i do hyper parameter search with
sagemaker
and if not what would you suggest
someone does if they want to find like a
good learning rate for example
yeah so they're like two different ways
you could do hyper parameter search by
using stage maker so the first way would
be using the sagemaker sdk and the
search maker like features so sagemaker
supports something called
automatic um i have a parameter search i
think where you can um define
like hyperparameter space and provide
this hyperparameter space to your
estimator and then sagemaker will
automatically run multiple training jobs
so um in our like on my example i
provided the hyperparameters in addition
to this you can provide like the
hyperparameter space and then sagemaker
will start multiple training jobs and
keeps an eye on okay which metrics i'm
going to track and do i want to maximize
it or minimize it and but you can also
like go the open source way and create a
training script using optuna ray or
whatever optimization tool you want to
use and then either run a longer
training so you could add like a loop
inside of your training script to run
like multiple iteration experiments and
then like save them to the hiking face
hub or add like early stoppings into it
or you could like
provide multiple hyperparameters and
then loop your sd mailer to start
multiple training jobs
cool cool
so i'm going to ask you a personal
question i've been asking everyone else
um so
yeah and your buyer says that you're
like the tech lead at hugging face for
the sagemaker partnership and also some
other projects you know what what does a
day in the life of philip look like at
hugging face
oh wow okay um so i'm from germany uh
this means like um i have um a lot of my
meetings are like in the evening or like
late evening i would say since aws is in
the us mostly so my normal morning is
starting
catching up on slack and everything
happened during the night since we're
like a global company and then working
on some tasks and normally i go into
or working out um before um lunch and
then have like a nice lunch break and
then the afternoon i have like all of
those nice meetings with aws people or
like with the hacking phase around the
world and then
that's basically it
but i would say like what kind of sorry
yeah i think i would say like
every day is like something new and you
need to be very flexible so you cannot
say okay i want to do like this for the
next five days you like always need to
adjust to the needs and what currently
is important to you
cool cool and i also know you do a lot
of work on like productionizing like
machine learning models or like making
them faster or smaller and essentially
all this crazy optimization stuff and i
was kind of curious to hear your
thoughts on like
you know one why does this matter why
can't i just you know
train my model and call it a day and two
where do you see like the sort of most
kind of exciting developments in this
like space of optimization of
transformers
yeah i think like so
you could of course use like your
vanilla model you have created but there
are like always two kind of leverage you
could use the one is maybe your model is
too slow to run inside of your product
so for example search is like the best
use case for it if i'm like a google
user i want to type in and want like my
get result immediately and i cannot wait
like a few hundred milliseconds or even
seconds to get my search result because
then i would start using bing or like
duckduckgo or like some different search
service
and the other leverage is of course the
smaller the model the less compute you
need to use and the less like money you
need to spend on and if you for example
if we take a look at g5 which i think is
around 400 gigabytes or something or you
need to have like at least a dozen gpu
to run it which is like way too
expensive for startups and then if we
take a look at a new
t0 plus model from the big science um
yeah organization which is i think 16
times smaller which also means 16 times
less expensive than running gpt free and
i think to be able to
give everyone access we the models need
to be small enough or cheap enough to
run so people can use it i mean nobody
helps it that a model can solve any task
if you cannot use it
yep yep definitely
and and i'm just wondering like what are
the um sort of
challenges that happen when you want to
make these models smaller like is it
just like pip install optimized model
or is it more complicated
yeah sadly it's more complicated but
like we are getting closer to just
running a optimized model x or model y
um but it like really depends on the
model architectures you are using and
then also on the task you're using so
for example sequence to sequence models
are way harder to optimize since you
have a lot of dynamic into it and you
have like the encoder model and the
decoder model and it's like it's not
static at all and if you want to
optimize or like the easiest
optimization step is basically to trace
your craft or basically to know in
advance with computation you want to do
so dynamic models are way harder to
optimize but i think we are making good
progress or like the whole deep learning
community is making good progress to
making optimizations easier and more
accessible
and i think in the future we will see a
lot more of this
and i mean like optimum the new open
source library is i guess one of the
best examples on how to leverage
optimization optimization techniques um
for air transformer models
yeah so for those who are interested um
phillip is referring to
um the optimum library so let's find it
and um
do you wanna just tell us in one minute
or 30 seconds what this is about
um
yeah i can give it a try i'm like not
the expert in it but optimum is
basically
you could see it as an additional layer
on top of the transformers library for
every like optimization for a specific
hardware provider which doesn't fit into
like the normal transformers repository
so as a like best example i would say we
can see a craft car ipu's which require
some changes to the trainer and to the
like training loop and those changes
were implemented into the optimum
library and then optimum again is
compatible with transformers so you can
use graphcore ipu's to train your
transformers model using optimum and
transformers and we don't need to worry
about breaking things inside of
transformers just for the ipu use case
awesome
so let me just have a quick look at the
forum
see if there's any last questions
okay so there's one more question um
this is maybe more of an aws question
let's uh just chuck it in the banner
so
the question is can we make assumptions
or comparisons between the gpu instances
that are available for this project on
aws and what a regular sort of colab gpu
offers
so i guess the question is like
you know i think matsuya mentioned that
we have like these p3 instances
and uh maybe the question is like if
someone wants to use collab themselves
and maybe pay for it with color pro you
know
do you what do you see roughly as the
price difference is there
i think it's hard to compare since like
colab is like a managed jupiter
environment and what we are going to use
with aws are like these virtual machine
and instance type so um you can use them
for the sagemaker notebook which i've
shown in my talk where you can use them
for the manage training we run and you
can like scale them up and like not
limited to the gpu you get when starting
your call-up environment so you always
know okay i want to use the nvidia a100
for my training why i want to use for
nvidia a100 for my training because i
want to use or to run it just in a
distributed way to be faster to iterate
more and to achieve better results
and i think it's hard to compare a like
apples with like
strawberries i would say and it really
depends on what you want to do
and it would be unfair to compare like a
collab as like as a free service with
subscriptions because they bring way
more than just your managed environment
i mean in collab i don't think you can
like easily collaborate and have
permissions across your organizations or
make sure that people can do certain
things
yep yep sorry about it definitely for
for the um like the community um event
you can like type in google ec2 instance
type and then you should find like an
aws documentation page where you can
search for p3
and the p3 um to spoil you um it
supports tesla v100 gpu and like the
smallest one has 16 gig of memory
and then the g4 which material mentioned
is an nvidia t4 tensor core unit so both
gpus are pretty good i would say
and
i guess better what you get with call it
free for now so you should definitely
join the community even to test them
nice
with that i think that's there's no more
questions so thank you once again philip
for joining us
and i will see you around in the next
couple of days on discord or in the
forums
awesome
hey